you
it's going to be scary I do not know
what I'm getting myself into I got word
in the chat in the twitch chat that this
is an opening out of the Vienna every
game will begin in the Frankenstein
Dracula variation position okay first
time I'm ever doing this let's see what
happens it's going to start at any
moment oh boy here we go let's see what
we got in store let's see what we can
learn here yeah oh my goodness
who's who's is to move it's my turn to
move oh no it's not even my move hahaha
um okay let's do this
I think or wow I don't even know what to
do I guess here Knight g5 oh they didn't
play Knight g5 I think Knight g5 has
really hurt you I better have something
for that and then next came a better
figure out something fast am i up upon
I'm up upon I got a full rack of pawns
lovely okay give me the F file they get
doubled pawns but I get the F file I'm
playing against the chest prince okay
let's stop that pawn from going any
further why did I do that
alright let's go here alright
go expand all right let's expand let's
keep expanding not so fast actually
pretty decent time advantage I'm going
to push and then push again mmm that's
so fast we exchanged LightSquared bishop
so yeah that seems like a good idea um
let's do this offer Queen exchange ooh
you sneaky Queen you you're very sneaky
I want to get my queen over here at my
queen defense so my rook is free to do
something else their Queen might be
trapped soon all for Queen exchange I'm
up upon and then just trade everything
King position King position and I don't
want to go any further actually let's do
this I'm going to give him back just to
break up their pawns rook activity their
pawns are now split and I'm hitting
pawns they're they've kicked it into a
higher gear on push is good fortunately
this happens to work out was not
calculated not even close to being
calculated need some time burners time
burners is what I need just push this
pawn I get a queen let's go down on time
back to tournament oh I better be
prepared are they going to get white I'm
gonna play this down upon I have to keep
in mind of this Knight g5 idea okay I
like this as a start Knight takes Knight
I got Knight g5 what are you doing about
95 yeah that's the this is the move that
I feared now you're having to deal with
it I better have an answer as black eye
I'm not quite sure um yeah let's run it
like this I get the pawn back okay so I
got the Bishop versus Knight position
it's castle Queen h5 and then pick up
the EH pawn and not so fast let's stop
them from castling Bishop g5
yeah Bishop g5 avoid the Queen exchange
they're going to grab this guy though
that's a pond I'll take them Bishop here
I guess now I want to save him eight h3
queen g4 offer Queen exchange now I'm up
on my pawn structure can get crunched
real soon let's just take take what the
pawn and let's kick him away first it's
a very weakening I realize get out of
pins ah scary oh oh I can't get barely
move I could barely move could barely
move
my big trouble here here I'm barely
defending ah um this is not good they
had something there they missed it I
don't know what I'm doing I got to move
him uh yeah I still don't know what I'm
doing I got to get rid of that night
it's terrible it's just a monster
where's my time I had to go faster gotta
go faster
now don't
you time burner just yet Forks not cool
stalemate after hope for stalemate maybe
if they put strip on maybe a stalemate
oh it's not
happen I'm down on time - oh my goodness
back to tournament yeah as soon as I
played f3 they really pounced on those
weaknesses g3 in particular oh man I got
to come up with something I'm gonna try
it oh it's not my move
first off and they have this a sacrifice
okay that's interesting that's a very
interesting start and now um no I'm not
up a piece okay I see I see what they
did there that's interesting but I've uh
I've done well to get my King castled by
hand and that pain is going to be
annoying okay yeah they did they had to
do something about that let's go here
maybe look for a sacrifice on h3 night
here annoying let's just rule it out all
together Queen b3 might be an idea
[Music]
it's just double f2 is vulnerable let's
secure my night position first well okay
they're going to kick me you're going to
kick me aren't you this is dropping but
f2 is dropping okay Queen to e1 is
probably strong although I have Bishop
takes h3 hmm I still have Bishop takes
h3 and this is held together by a thread
okay don't really like that move let's
do this I'm threatening mate Queen h3
now I'm not actually threatening mate
but this is strong I get the knight
actually yeah this is working rook here
Bishop takes your stuff or just the
bishop move with the discovered check
yeah Bishop move is the main threat
let's just take here and then okay yeah
this is working
check and then this will be mate yeah
okay so that's an interesting start to
do that sacrifice on f7 hmm I bet you a
lot of the players in this tournament
are learning a different tricks from
their opponent um yeah let's give that
one a go I like that idea
um maybe I don't like that idea
maybe that isn't really a good option
let's see if I could distract black from
doing rook F 8 and then tucking the King
away yeah I'm going to try this maybe
Queen h5 challenge the center real soon
maybe take with the Queen okay if I take
here so I could get my night out so I'm
up a pond Bishop g4 gonna bother me
let's do this yes I am up upon so here
and I guess just reinforced d4 let's do
with the piece develop maybe dropping c2
not anymore
let's take with the night maybe
recapture on f1 with a knight okay
Queen b3 check I have and then are they
going to block with the bishop yes they
are
let's come here trade the Knights no
that was a bad move I couldn't take with
the rook because of Bishop d5 okay okay
I have my seventh rank defended I'm
still Papon let's get him out of there
just helps my king if they take and they
did they're in a pin they'll get out of
it with the check and I'm going to come
back to g1 oh they didn't get out of it
let's do this stop the rook move with
check I want to keep them in a pin and
I'm going to do this take with the pawn
okay so this is this is good King
position and up an extra I'm up upon
really strong King position so let's get
this guy working let's save him first
B 4 C 5 C anchor my knight in there
Capri move this
down on time and do some tricky night
stuff it's difficult to defend against
these night moves Bishop versus Knight
okay back determine who I'm just going
to develop I don't like this idea of
sacking on f7 Knight g5 maybe I'll take
on this east six square in a different
way see what they do they stuff a little
tunnel it'll time to think about their
first move I guess like g5 it's a scary
move what do you do about that oh yeah
what are you doing about f7 I feel your
pain I feel your pain okay
yeah let's take here Queens off um oh
they're going to take with the knight
but I have a really strong Knight right
here let's develop first let them kick
the night before I just voluntarily
retreat so I'm not down upon here am i
let's do this
maybe maybe g4 first to stop this
advance keep him here
King position rook h4 earlier would have
been better I think I wouldn't dislodge
the knight a a five and then B five I
don't know if I'm really going about it
the correct way okay now I could try
this and then Knight here once the rook
defends and then scoop this guy up take
here okay get my knight right back to
this beautiful square stop Knight here
although there is this move oh I dropped
upon okay hmm he's but he's dead though
he's a cooked bishop got him target this
poem we're doing alright on the clock
hitting east six how do they defend that
okay
sure what this does weakens g3 grab that
pawn I have a pass or no let's just come
all the way back and push I really care
about my a pawn let's get behind and
push again offer in exchange keep
pushing he's passed I don't want to
invite their Knight forward let's keep
him boxed out King position this is a
free pawn looking at a fork discoveries
mates pigs
I mean discoveries mates pigs who else
right now is saying that very line who
else says those very three words right
in a row discoveries mates pigs only in
a chess game only in a chess game will
you ever hear those three words are
right in a row
watch out for the discoveries mates and
pigs very deadly very very deadly
that's a fork the Kings trying to hunt
my knight down he's in the corner he is
definitely in the corner let's open it
up
I want to rescue my knight I'll take him
he's passed make you struggle to get him
hopefully get out of there you need to
find a new home keep pressure there it
is that's one Pig ah let's just go here
in here really trying to get at their
King and let's just defend this now run
here my rook is an animal he really is
doing beautiful things I want to
exchange dark square bishop s' okay No
keep him on the seventh silly okay
because now you get to hunt him down you
have a past a pawn all right I want to
dislodge this bishop I want to get at
that a jeep on doing this so I could
play ch4 so Bishop takes isn't happening
with check here next all right I'm going
to do this
the knight is no good making two one two
cannot be avoided actually got it what
have I learned on the black end in this
opening it's scary it's definitely scary
um 21 18 18 I'm at 14 checked out 22 we
might get paired up I think he just
finished cuz he popped up there 64
players in this one in the Frankenstein
and Dracula variation arena we have okay
Kovac now let's see what he throws at me
oh man I haven't seen this one oh you
got to do this right oh oh man
um here oh yeah I get to Castle now and
defend here it should be fine I think an
earlier night move here was good okay
stealth upon let's stop Knight g5 oh
they're still trying for tricks huh
let's do this release the pressure on f7
now I could go here I don't want to take
that night I'm gonna get hurt
Bishop e6 maybe let's defend this pawn
can I do that move crazy
craziness let's go here let's push them
around try to at least take care you
capture it - Queen this should be
alright
throw in a check night here maybe Bishop
takes pawn look at the C 2 square defend
here as well uh-huh threaten it trade
and then take here their King is in some
serious serious trouble my knight is a
beast he's a beast
maybe sacrifice right ah no he's too
good
you got to remove the glue I'm also on
b2 didn't realized that let's take first
sniff him super valuable let's push hang
on to him
uh-huh hit the Queen hit this pawn go
here maybe let's go here no matter what
can have this let's break down oh boy
really not something you want to do
let's just break it up don't make me
don't make me man
don't make me don't do time burners
what's the clock situation go fast
please um am i throwing any checks oh my
goodness I'm down oh man I wasn't able
to throw in any good check are you
kidding me wow he must have been dodging
checks like a genius like a genius ah
come on one just get one check just one
check could I could I've landed just one
check ah man his King must his king
should play the lottery he should really
play the lottery right now like withdraw
from this
Tournament and just go and play the
Powerball Wow I think he guessed right
man I think he did a lot of guessing
right oh my goodness Wow yeah had to be
how it went down man it had to be Oh
okay Bishop find something good to do
right hit the d3 pawn it's a matter with
you
grab upon it's all everything's falling
let's just trade a little bit they're
gonna get a passed pawn let's make sure
he's tracked down soon let's keep the
rook around mmm here I'll support him if
he's challenged yeah if the knight can't
move yeah I get that guy and now just
come back over here I guess I learned a
pin the rook moves I hit the night let's
get out of the pin stop the rook from
invading challenge the knight back up
here
let's take I could advance and I do this
oh they missed the lateral move probably
resign here or not okay I have enough
time with this one I have enough time
with this one okay they resigned yeah
they resigned back to tournament I'm not
in the front page okay I need to get to
the front page
31:26 is where the top guys are out I
think this is a good start just
developing Knight to f3 yeah I like this
pinpointing f7 stuff and I like getting
the pawn back oh that must have been a
mouse slip or is it or is it no can't be
you're not getting my knight back let's
take here and my knight is rescued yeah
he's rescued they resigned
tournament nice I'll take it frontpage
far away though thirty five twenty six
twenty four twenty three twenty twenty
twenty eighteen man ok there are 67 a
few more entered in this one less than
ten minutes yeah let's keep going with
it no you know I want to try that Queen
h5 move yeah I forget who did that
against me but that Queen h5 move is
interesting yeah I'm going to try Queen
h5 next time as white yeah there is a
really good response to this pressure
get step 7
I know man I know my getting another
another fork no oh let's just develop
he's got to be pretty annoying can't
move the bishop okay well you can but G
drops this is a good home for the king
up upon know keep my knight on f5 no I'm
going to voluntarily retreat h5 if I
supported it and now we'll do this look
at controlling some squares okay they
went a little too fast with that one and
get the a pond they resigned no what
no oh they resigned they they offered a
draw maybe accidentally I thought I was
close to accepting him what you dare
accept a draw offer in that position
never okay that can't be good
now I get to play in the center with
tempo stop them from counseling maybe if
they don't play d4 no okay threatening
to win the bishop with c5 b5 and then
this maybe okay let's do this they
Castle I have this I have us nice wall
phones also I'm dropping upon yeah you
better do this right now
they have a bishop check probably should
have taken the other way got do that I
guess he was hit too many times I can't
rely upon him is
a defender anymore pinpoint efore
question this Bishop with h6 it's a free
pawn I'm going to take them box out the
night dropping this sing on to them
that's a bad square should reserved it
for my night okay mmm okay this is a
really strong pawn right here just going
to look to advance yeah these guys keep
pushing tsunami of ponds and coming and
coming and okay actually get this oh
they could take with the rock what am i
doing why did I think they had to take
another way this might actually still be
winning for me now that's a stretch
you're getting ahead of yourself oh
you're dropping a piece all right pick
one
choose one none of the above they went
with I got the Queen they don't have any
time so they have to do fast moves fast
moves no time okay they're down on time
back to tournament 47:31 2626 can I get
to the podium we're going to see I want
to try to get third oh boy let's see
what he throws at me yeah I think this
is a must
okay Queen trade interesting line all
right
it's Castle um I guess here and then
here okay get him out of there trade ah
okay here their night here is gonna be
annoying very annoying very very
annoying yes super annoying my night was
actually trapped I think g4 would have
been good okay I got a reposition yeah
they're stopping
from trading nights get to f5 even at
the cost of structural defect major
piece sending I don't know how bad this
is due to the king position I could even
pivot on e5 and dislodge the King should
it be captured otherwise I could maybe
take control over this file take what
the pond dislodge the King position get
this guy going they have a majority I
think this now they get to that pond now
this actually this is a good move ah
let's go here I want to keep these guys
like so yeah not quite sure what to do
yeah I really have to keep these guys
here I can't really I need to keep
pressure on that pond let's come over
here give a check I get a good King
position now actually I think that was a
mistake
oh um here and then pawn push where's my
time Wow um I give a check um how we
doing
how are you doing oh I'm still here I'm
still here I know a quiet I was just
stunned at why I wasn't able to move
that was stalemate folks that was stale
me that was still me don't be scared I'm
still here I have to I have to point
that out by the way because the stream
went down before so there might be some
fear some fear of maybe the Comcast
gambit or you know something wrong with
the Internet okay I'm not gonna try
Queen h5 against this guy
let's see what they have in store here
is d5 really the move let's see that's
whatever oh that's another way to do it
huh uh-huh
really so I get this fork and they have
that okay what happens if I do this
because I'm on e5 and the rook and I'm
defending the bishop now I'll take care
that all right but sure takes pawn
I'll take here and then here I'm missing
and then maybe give a check first and
then take on this square this is so
scary I want to take like this sack
apiece oh my goodness
hit that resigned button now really
wanted it twice oh oh no wait why did I
get the resize button I wasn't in check
I was thinking I'm in check I thought
that that was a fork oh for some reason
I thought I was in a fork there ah
premature resignation man you never want
to do that Bishop g4 was not hitting
with check you goof ah man that was
actually an interesting game - an
interesting variation wasn't really much
of a game
okay get out of here man get out of here
this is gonna be the last game I think
yeah he's having a tough day right there
that guy tough day tough day spin and
stuff he's bad he's pinned in bad he's
pinned and bad that's tough
if you're pinned and bad here you're
struggling you know alright let's let's
hit this guy I could have taken him he's
going to be the one to kill me he's
pinned not bad in this case night check
or queen shocking coming get some
material the queen or the rook or the
exchange I'm on the knight get to h2
maybe let's do it no matter what
take my rook ah h2 again he's running
for his life h2 again keep the Queens on
the board
Bishop check here take the knight so
we're going to finish 16 seconds they
resigned back to tournament and that's
going to do it oh just out a third place
or excuse me uh yeah I had an
opportunity for maybe third mmm man
final standings are fifty nine thirty
eight thirty two thirty two thirty
alright that was interesting to safe a
feast I had no idea what I was getting
myself into
choosing that variation gg's all I want
to go back to this game that I resigned
um yeah let me see this I don't know
what I was thinking is thinking of it a
fork here I'm not in a fork I'm in some
trouble though maybe it still is
reasonable you know cuz of a oh yeah no
look at this this is good for me what
though what in the world Queen takes
here oh I'm actually getting mated this
square what should have I done though Oh
Knight takes their chop-chop and it
likes me just by a little bit a rook oh
man unbelievable never never resign in
a1 position that's what I learned in
this Dracula Frankenstein variation okay
ah okay
that was interesting that was a first
and that was interesting
[Music]